VI HART: Yo, Brady.
It's Vi Hart, and as promised,
I'm going throw you a Yahtzee.
But to make it easier, I'm going
to use tetrahedral dice,
but to make it harder
again-- ooh, that
was four out of five.
To make it harder again, I'm
going to use six of them.
So you figure that out.
Tetrahedral dice have many
survival advantages over the
cubular dice, among which is
that they are very difficult
to pick up because
they're pointy.
So I'm going to have to sweep
them off the table.
They also don't roll as far as
your cube dice because they
have sharper angles.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are at roll number 100, as
you can see by the counter
that I'm pressing with my foot,
which means it's time--
time for your next tetrahedral
superiority fact.
Tetrahedra are also superior
to the cube in that they
always end point-up.
They don't have the faces
opposite each other, unlike a
cube and, in fact, all other
platonic solids.
When they land on the face, the
other face is facing up.
But these have the point facing
up, which means that
they are dangerous as a natural
defense, which is I
guess why caltrops are designed
as a tetrahedron.
They have tetrahedral
points, so that when
you throw them at--
they're always going
to land point-up.
And if you stepped on one
of these, it would hurt.
Unlike the cube, which
is weak and soft.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've gotten past 200.
Time for your next tetrahedral
survival advantage fact.
Tetrahedra don't roll as easily
as cube dice, because
they have this kind
of sharper angle.
They are less likely
to accidentally
get lost and lonely.
Moving onward.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
So our 300th roll tetrahedron
fact time.
As a platonic solid, Plato
thought that the tetrahedron
represented the element of fire,
because one, they're
pointy and they hurt you like
fire hurts you, and related to
the fact that they don't
roll easily, unlike the
icosahedron, which rolls so
easily, with that very wide
angle, that it rolls kind
of like water does.
So that's what the icosahedron
was water, tetrahedron was
fire, and the cube, being stable
and boring, is earth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh!
I guess I got it.
Man, and here I was busily
trying to think of more
tetrahedron facts.
I did not expect to get
it this soon at all.
I'm on 382.
Here I was just thinking that I
should have gotten an intern
to do this for me and that I was
going to have nightmares
of tetrahedral dice
attacking me.
But this actually
wasn't that bad.
And yet I don't think the
chances of six four-sided dice
is actually that much lower
than of five cubes.
(SINGING) Brady, I got a
Yahtzee, I got a Yahtzee.
Oh!
Two.
Hey, Brady, it's
the number two.
Just for you.
Isn't that appropriate?
BRADY HARAN: Oh, oh, ooh.
Ah, ow!
VI HART: Sorry, 2.
But you know, you look
good this way.
All right.
I guess I might as well go
through some other tetrahedral
dice facts, although I don't
ever want to move my Yahtzee
from being a Yahtzee
ever again.
Keeping those 2s up.
Tetrahedra are also superior to
the cube in that, well, as
a survival advantage,
cubes pack space.
So like if you have a lot of
cubes, they might pack
together nice and tightly
like this.
Which you might think is a plus,
because they use space
very efficiently.
But on the other hand, if you
get your cube all surrounded
tightly by other cubes, the
cubes might suffocate and die.
Whereas the tetrahedra, though
they look almost like they
might kind of pack space, like
you can fit five of them
around like this and it looks
like they almost fit
perfectly, but they don't.
There's just like a
tiny little gap.
And this gap enables even a
super-close-huddling group of
tetrahedra to breathe
and not suffocate.
I thought I was going to be in
for a whole afternoon of
tetrahedron mania.